all right our exclusive reporting on the
DOJ we can report right now that the
missing FBI text messages we'll tell you
about it in a second this is a
game-changing development but first
President Trump is letting the Special
Counsel Robert Muller know that there is
no collusion and he has nothing to hide
listen to this all right with those
lawyers approved that makes sense but is
that the smart play sounds like game on
to me the Drudge Report tonight has this
headline up and it sums it up perfectly
Trump stairs down Muller I'll do it
under oath now judge Jeanine Pirro
she'll join us later with legal reaction
now also tonight the walls are closing
in on those responsible for this massive
corruption abuse of power at the top
levels of government in what we are now
calling state-sponsored sabotage now
with this flood of damning news exposing
all this malfeasance the Special Counsel
Robert Muller and it's folks people in
the media are now working overtime they
want to create as many distractions as
possible and discredit anybody that's
telling the truth like us here on the
Fox News Channel for daring to report on
the truth now to be perfectly clear for
those that don't pay attention and want
to advance lies and false narratives we
are not and never have been and never
will be talking about rank-and-file
members of the FBI the DOJ and the
intelligence community they honor us
with their service every day and there's
no show on television that has and will
continue to support these hard-working
people that do such a service to their
country but the criminal wrongdoing that
we are exposing has to do with only a
few select Obama administration top
bureaucrats who thought that they knew
better than you did about who should be
your president now the liberal media is
engaged in a total smear campaign they
want to shut up people like me and Gregg
Jarrett and Sarah Carter and
Soloman and tom Fitton and victoria tun
singh and so many others they want to
conceal the truth now we've always had
the utmost respect for the FBI I've had
family in the FBI and the intelligence
community and police officers and
firefighters and the military now can
the liberal media say the same for
themselves we know the answer how many
times have you heard them attack people
in uniform those that service as much as
they do now that we're getting closer
and closer every single night in
uncovering this huge historic massive
scandal the media is rushing to slander
and discredit those of us that are
exposing this at the end of the day
every one of these so-called journalists
at these so-called news networks are
going to look like fools that we already
know that they are the same people who
have been clinging to a sinking lifeboat
of this phony Trump Russia collusion
story it's been a year and they still
cannot admit that they've been
completely wrong there's no evidence and
in many instances they're flat-out lying
and now since none of this has worked
well the media is now doing the bidding
of robert muller they're breathless
hysterical reporting about what the
special counsel is doing don't believe
me let your own I see a dizzying 24
hours in the Russia investigation no
longer just inching toward the president
this morning it is more like careening
happening now breaking news closing in
the special councils Russia probe closes
in on the president and his inner circle
after 24 hours of bombshell reports and
developments another one Justin
CNN has now learned that the special
counsel robert muller
wants to question the president's former
white White House chief strategist Steve
Bannon the outline of an obstruction of
justice case
filling in bit by bit as NBC's first
reading political team notes if the
optics around Bill Clinton's tarmac
meeting with Loretta Lynch were bad this
is quote a hundred times worse it was a
day of Revelations in the Russia probe
if there's any day to be watching re it
is today Russia Russia Russia a lot
going on now if you noticed anytime
there's big breaking news about this
massive government abuse of power that
we're on foot that's unfolding every
night on this show all of a sudden three
or four stories about the special
counsels investigation in the media
they're all over the place and it
spreads like wildfire within their own
echo chamber so predictable at this
point the media is out of control with
their bias it's painfully obvious and by
the way a lot of their information I
believe when all is said and done is
probably coming from Robert Muller and
of course his Liberal Democratic hacks
that have been pushing this themselves
now also tonight big developments about
the explosive classified memo exposing
FISA abuses against the Trump campaign
Fox News is reporting the Department of
Justice is now asking the House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez to not publicly release the memo
that we deserve now to the DOJ do they
not understand Congress has oversight
over them they're investigating them
they don't have to hand the memo over to
anybody in spite of what the liberal
media says they shouldn't do it now this
is why we are once again calling on you
the American people to call up your
members of Congress the man the memo be
released release the memo hashtag
released the memo call the number on
your screen
two oh two two to four thirty one twenty
one tell Congress the truth about one of
the biggest scandals in American history
and we have a right to know also
breaking this hour this is huge new
information about the missing struck
page text messages remember five months
a very critical time period sources are
exclusively telling me tonight multiple
sources that the Department of Justice
is as we speak in the process of
successfully recovering many of those
text messages in that five month period
of time from the trumpeting FBI
officials Peter struck and Lisa Paige
the DOJ is also trying to track down
their mobile phones this is huge because
those texts are during that critical
time during the so-called Russia
investigation here's a big question
tonight was a deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe cell phone impacted by this
so-called glitch McCabe he was Lisa
Paige's boss and both she and struck
talked about quote the insurance policy
in Andy's office we believe that was
McCabe and also brand-new tonight we
have new revelations about one of the
lawyers that is now representing
disgraced former FBI director soon to be
probably investigated national
embarrassment James Comey according to
BuzzFeed one of commis attorneys turns
out as his Columbia Law professor buddy
the guy he leaked a memo to to the New
York Times because he wanted a special
counsel appointed which turned out to be
oh commis other BFF robert muller you
can't make this up in a spy novel it's
one giant incestuous circle of
corruption and we have even more proof
James Comey testified and remember that
he gave his classified memos to Robert
Muller and according to the reports the
special counsel interviewed Comey about
his memos last year by the way they also
collaborated before he testified those
memos contain classified information
they were created on government
computers so Comey broke the law by
removing them from the FBI but it's
clear that Muller didn't care about any
of that does their best friends
Mulder's main focus is and has been and
continues to be carrying out a
witch-hunt to unseat a duly elected
president of the United States
presidents from it's ridiculous and it's
an abomination to our Constitution and
the rule of law and as you have seen by
watching the show the past couple of
nights well there have been so much
breaking news about the FBI text
messages that we've been able to cover
all of this I want to go back and I want
to make sure you're up to speed
highlight a couple of very important
pieces of information
now remember Senator Ron Johnson
revealing with Bret Baier last night
that an informant told him that there
was some sort of anti Trump quote secret
society within the FBI
senator Johnson explaining it on special
report take a look what this is all
about is further evidence of corruption
more than bias the corruption at the
highest levels of the FBI in that secret
society we have we have an informant
that's talking about a group they were
holding secret meetings off-site there
are there's so much smoke here there's
so much suspicion let's stop there
a secret society the secret meetings off
side of the Justice Department correct
and you have an informant saying that
yes there's anything more about that no
we have to dig into it that's that's
this is not a distraction again this is
this is bias potentially corruption at
the highest levels of the FBI really
secret societies you can't make this
stuff up ABC News they have obtained
this particular text message and they're
actually questioning if it was all a
joke we'll let you decide Lisa page
writing Peter struck are you even going
to give out your calendars seems kind of
depressing maybe it should just be the
first meeting of the secret society
senator Johnson is saying that he's
trying to get to the bottom of it as he
should and senator Johnson is also
making news by releasing text messages
from anti-trump FBI lovers Peter struck
and Lisa page that also highlight even
further their extreme bias now just
after midnight on May 19th remember it
was gone from December 14th to what the
16th of May and then Muller was
appointed and all of a sudden they
started reappearing again but struck
appears to be talking about getting an
offer to join Muller's investigation
this is key and by the way rights here
struck my answer is no no in the lead
division and then I think wait a case
will be in the history books a chapter
much like you tell me about my extra
time in the field and all the cases
would you trade it a million people sit
in and an odd staff jobs I didn't quite
get that this is a chance to do well it
may be the most important case of our
lives by the way the same guy that was
saying earlier there's no there there 30
minutes later struck ass page the
question an investigation leading to
impeachment so that struck have inside
knowledge about what Robert Muller's end
goal was
going to be because that statement from
struck contradicts what he said when he
was talking about the possibility of
Trump Russia collusion on May 19 two
days after Muller was appointed you may
remember the time frame he says you and
I both know the odds are nothing and if
I thought it was likely I'd be there
meaning with Muller no question I
hesitated in part because of my gut
sense and concerned there's no big there
there why would I want to do that so
struck despite his rampant bias knew
from the beginning Muller was leading a
witch-hunt and struck would know because
he was the top intelligence official at
the FBI and he's the guy that signed the
papers that started the entire Russian
investigation now struck also dropped
this bombshell about the Clinton email
investigation writing for me and this
case I personally have a sense of
unfinished business I Unleashed it with
my weld the mid-year exam his mie which
was the FBI's code name for the Clinton
investigation now I need to fix it and
finish it fix it and finish it struck is
texting this May 19th
remember when he we know Hillary Clinton
wasn't even interviewed till the fourth
of July weekend about her email server
scandal on the 4th of July now remember
it's at this point that struck and
called me and others were drafting the
exoneration on May the second before
they talked to Clinton interviewed
Clinton and 17 other key witnesses and
struck in Page while they suggest in
text on July 1st just four days before
commis announcement three days before
they interview Hillary about Clinton
that both of them and the former
attorney general Loretta Lynch all knew
that Clinton wouldn't be prosecuted its
smoking gun evidence what more would you
need struck call me Loretta Lynch they
all knew the fix was in it was rigged
let me connect the dots for you so you
got deep state actors you got these
people top people at the FBI struck
Paige Comey and then at the DOJ the AG
Loretta Lynch and of course Andrew
McCabe shielding Hillary Clinton from
prosecution even though it is obvious
incontrovertible she committed felonies
and broke the law because they wanted
her
to stay in the race and defeat in the
election Donald Trump
now remember language in the exoneration
statement was changed from what was
breaking the law the legal standard
gross negligence - extreme carelessness
and then you had Hillary Clinton
shelling out what over 12 million
dollars for an unverified salacious
dossier
with Russian propaganda and lies because
she wanted to rig the general election
against Trump after all she's the same
woman that rigged the primaries
according to Donna Brazile against
Bernie Bernie Sanders and on top of that
he has a backup Obama deep state
officials they used this fabricated
dossier to obtain a FISA warrant in
other words the Hillary bought and paid
paid for phony Russian dossier to spy on
an opposition candidate Donald Trump in
an election year and then as a
president-elect talk about Watergate
this is Watergate on steroids and human
growth hormone the constitutional
violations are severe and historically
unprecedented in this country you have
deep state actors using and abusing the
powerful tools of intelligence that we
give them to protect this country and
covering up Hillary Clinton's crime
because they wanted her to stay in the
race not be indicted because they
thought they knew better than you who
should be the president and more
importantly they thought they would
never get caught they never thought
Clinton was going to lose now tonight it
is time for the Attorney General by the
way good job at the DOJ tonight by
actually finding and now recovering some
of the missing five months of text
messages but set but the Attorney
General Sessions and he needs to I would
argue tonight appoint a second Special
Counsel why to investigate and prosecute
every single person that we are talking
about involved in this